- Do you ever get mistaken for Rob Lowe?
(all laughing)
- I just had him on as-
- [Chynna] Well you're both,
- Rob is...
- [Chynna] you know, not hard on the eyes.
You guys could be brother twins.
- [Ian] Rob is awesome.
(laughing)
He was so sweet.
He walked up to my wife,
he walked up to Nikki Reed at a,
I think it was a Golden
Globes party or something,
and he walked up to her,
and she'd never met him,
and he walked up to her
and he grabbed her face, and he just said,
"This is what you're gonna
be looking at in 15 years."
(clapping)
(audience laughing)
- [Chynna] No, are you serious?
- Yeah.
(laughing)
And he was so sweet and
respectful about it.
And she just--
- This is what you're going
to be looking at in 15-
- But any woman that is
that close to Rob Lowe
is sort of like, whoa!
(all laughing)
And it was very sweet.
Really sweet man, awesome.